Every year we consume immense quantities
of goods that make their way from one side of
the planet to the other.
But have you ever wondered how this enormous
flow of goods is organized, so that stuff made in
China is available in stores in rural Montana?
It happens because formal organizations make
it happen.
Our world is structured by formal organizations,
and life as we now know it can’t exist without them.
But it's not all rainbows and butterflies
and incredibly extensive trade networks,
because within these organizations lurk some
pretty substantial dangers.
[Theme Music]
OK so when I talk about formal organizations,
what does that mean?
Like, I gotta wear a cocktail dress
or a black tie?
And is there, I dunno, a casual organization
that I can be part of instead?
Where people just wear flip flops and maybe
go floating?
Well, sociologists think of formal organizations as
groups that are organized to achieve goals efficiently.
Now, that’s obviously incredibly broad.
That’s why formal organizations are so
diverse – they include everything from the
IRS to Google to your local PTA.
But you can understand these kinds of
groups a bit better, by thinking about the three
main types of formal organizations:
Utilitarian organizations, for example, serve
some function for their members.
Businesses pay their employees, and schools
teach their students – and also pay their teachers.
Normative organizations, sometimes called
voluntary associations, are organizations
that people join as volunteers.
They're called "normative" because people
join them to pursue some goal that they think
is morally worthwhile.
This includes charities like the Red Cross,
but also political parties and religious organizations.
Finally, coercive organizations are ones
where you don’t have a say in whether you’re
a member or not.
People are coerced into joining these organizations,
often as punishment – as in prisons – or
treatment – say, through involuntary commitment
into a psychiatric hospital.
Now, these are all modern-day examples,
but formal organizations have been around
basically forever:
They built the pyramids, they collected
taxes across the Roman Empire, and they helped
organize monasteries and convents.
But, there is a major difference between those
formal organizations and modern ones.
And that difference is between traditional
and rational worldviews.
This goes back to our friend Max Weber, who
you (hopefully) remember from episode 9.
A traditional world view takes the basic set-up
of the world as given:
The way previous generations did things
– their values and techniques –
is thought to be basically the right way.
A rational world view, on the other hand, sees everything as up for grabs, and tries to find the most efficient way to accomplish a given task through critical thinking and calculation.
It's the transition from traditional to rational
worldviews, or the rationalization of society,
that ushered in modernity for Weber, and we can
see this rationality at work in an especially pervasive
kind of formal organization: the bureaucracy.
A bureaucracy is an organization that’s
been rationally constructed to do things efficiently.
And according to Weber, every bureaucracy has
six main things in common, which we introduced
in episode 9, but to recap:
Its members each have specialized roles that
fit together in a hierarchy –
that is, a clear chain of command linked by
formal, written communications.
Members of a bureaucracy also complete their work with technical competence, treating colleagues and customers without regard for their individual, personal traits:
That is, everyone’s treated
impersonally.
And all of this functions according to detailed
rules and regulations, literally "by the book."
These six traits make bureaucracies extremely
efficient at what they do.
But the very things that make bureaucracies
effective also cause their share of problems.
One problem is just that, sometimes, bureaucracies
are not actually that efficient.
Since bureaucracies are strictly hierarchical
and rule-based, those rules can sometimes
get in the way.
This is what people mean when they talk about
bureaucratic "red tape."
And that focus on rules leads to another kind
of inefficiency: bureaucratic ritualism.
In this case, the rules become a kind of
end in themselves, ultimately interfering with
the organization's goals.
Faith in the rules can become just as damaging
as faith in tradition ever was.
And a group’s goals can even shift so much
that it comes down with what’s known as
bureaucratic inertia.
This is where an organization’s ultimate
goal becomes just to perpetuate itself, to
keep existing.
This can be an intentional choice,
made by those who have the most to lose if
the organization were to disappear.
But it can also happen just because its members
believe that the organization does good work.
And it's not just that bureaucracies aren't
always efficient, or that their goals change:
Their hierarchies create another problem,
the problem of oligarchy, or the rule of the
many by the few.
Now, of course a hierarchical organization
is going to be an oligarchy.
After all, in a hierarchy, the people at the top
make decisions for everyone else to carry out.
This is partly what Weber thought helped make
bureaucracies so efficient.
But in a lot of bureaucracies, like democratic
governments, the people at the top of the hierarchy are
elected, or are appointed by people who are elected.
So even if they're giving orders, it should still be
considered a democratic organization, right?
Well, here's where another sociologist, Robert
Michels, saw a problem.
He called it the iron law of oligarchy.
He argued that regardless of how democratic
a bureaucracy is in theory, in practice, it always
tends toward pure oligarchy.
The people at the top may be elected, but
because of their position of power, they're actually
insulated from the people who elected them.
And even if the people in power are voted out,
those who replace them just become like the ones they
replaced, because of the way the system is structured.
Finally, what Weber saw as the worst
danger of bureaucracy was something called
bureaucratic alienation.
Bureaucracies are supposed to run with machine-like
efficiency, consistency, and calculability.
But people aren’t machines.
So, bureaucracies can be dehumanizing to those
who work in them and those they serve.
When a clerk at the DMV can’t help you
because you didn’t follow some obscure rule,
they’re doing their job right.
And if they exercise their personal, reasoned
judgement and ignore the rule, they’re doing
their job wrong.
To be a good bureaucrat is not to think for
yourself, but to be a good cog in the machine.
Despite all these problems, we still see rationalization
all over the place, including in the workplace,
through what’s known as scientific management.
Scientific management is a system devised by
American engineer Frederik Taylor, who, in the early
1900s, sought to make industry work more efficiently.
He came up with a process in which
management closely observes and systematizes
how workers do their jobs,
so that those jobs could be refined
over time, making them more efficient.
Taylor’s ideas were incredibly influential, and
in time, companies across the US adopted them.
So, from governments to corporations, the
bureaucratic model of formal organizations has
taken hold to be a regular part of modern life.
But in addition to the problems that bureaucracy
can cause, American formal organizations in particular
have faced many challenges over the last century,
due to changes in what's called
the organizational environment.
Simply put, that’s just the environment
in which organizations exist and operate.
The organizational environment includes things
like technology, political and economic trends,
and population patterns.
And in the US, one the main challenges that formal
organizations have faced is the growing recognition that
many of them were either racist or sexist or both.
Following the civil rights and feminist movements
in the 1960s and 70s, hiring practices that excluded
people who weren't white men came under
increasing fire.
While excluding job candidates on the basis
of race or gender might seem to go against
Weber's idea of technical competence,
it's important to understand that that's not
how those doing the hiring saw it.
Often, they believed that those who were excluded
were simply incapable of doing the work.
Until they were forced to do otherwise by
changes in the organizational environment,
many were quite happy to go on excluding large
swaths of their talent pools.
More recently, another challenge has come
in the form of big economic shifts, and the
changing nature of work itself.
As the US transitions from an industrial to postindustrial economy, there are fewer manufacturing jobs, and more jobs based around creating and processing information.
Frederik Taylor’s vision of work – as a
series of discrete, rote tasks – might have been
a good way to improve assembly lines.
But applying it to things like programming,
design, or marketing just hasn’t worked.
As a result, we’ve seen a lot of important
changes in the organizations that house these
of newer kinds jobs:
Workers have more creative freedom, and
more flexibility around when and where they work,
and organizational hierarchies have flattened.
Compared to old style bureaucracies, average
employees in the information industry have a much
more direct connection to their leadership.
But not everything has changed in the American
workplace.
While big changes have taken place in
high-skill jobs that require creative work,
lower-skilled jobs, which are now mostly in
the service sector, are just as amenable to Taylor's
scientific management as ever.
And rationalization is alive and well in many
other aspects of society, too.
If anything, it continues to spread.
Sociologist George Ritzer has called this
the McDonaldization of Society:
the process by which the principles of
the fast food restaurant have come to
dominate the whole of society.
Few things, after all, are more hyper-rational
than fast food.
The whole industry is based on the principles of
efficiency, predictability, uniformity, and control.
The point of fast food is that you get your
food quickly, and just as you expect it.
And that’s because the way the food is made
is precisely controlled.
And Ritzer argues that these principles are
having an growing impact in our society at large.
In education, for instance, we see more emphasis on
standardized tests and tightly controlled curricula that
run students through the system in 4 years flat.
All of this brings us to what Ritzer calls
the irrationality of rationality.
As we saw with bureaucratic ritualism
and alienation, rational systems are often
unreasonable, impersonal.
The reliance on rules and procedures can leave no
room for independent judgment, basically denying
people their status as independent thinking beings.
So, rational formal organizations are a necessary
part of our world.
They’re how goods from all over the world
end up on shelves here in Montana.
But they're also a part of modern life that
deserves our close attention.
Today we learned about formal organizations.
We talked about the historical process of
rationalization and its impact on organizations
in the form of bureaucracy.
We discussed how organizations change in response
to their organizational environment.
Finally, we talked about the negative consequences
of rationalization in organizations.
Crash Course Sociology is filmed in the Dr. Cheryl
C. Kinney Studio in Missoula, MT, and it’s made
with the help of all of these nice people.
Our animation team is Thought Cafe and Crash
Course is made with Adobe Creative Cloud.
If you'd like to keep Crash Course free for
everyone, forever, you can support the series
at Patreon,
a crowdfunding platform that allows
you to support the content you love.
Thank you to all of our patrons for making
Crash Course possible with their continued
support.